what screenwriting mistakes have you
made in your earlier work
that you've corrected oh so many
mistakes in my early work uh the biggest
one
and it still survives in a short film
that i made uh
was monologues oh my god i used to write
some obscenely long
pretentious monologues as you can
probably tell i've
very opinionated about things you know
kind of
philosophical about things and i would
put
way too much that into my characters and
it was annoying
and i feel bad for the actors i had to
try and deliver those things um
that was the big one learning to you
know the obvious thing
show not tell uh that was hard for me
uh it really took
trusting my own abilities as a filmmaker
trusting the audience as another big
part of it you know
we've all got this idea that because
fast nefarious is so popular because
kind of
derivative films are so popular that
audiences aren't smart
they are smart just sometimes they want
to turn their brain off but if you're
making a film that allow that
encourages them to turn their brain on
they'll go just as deep as you want them
to go
and so that to me was a big part of it
is
learning to write better for sure
learning to write smarter
but then also trusting that i don't have
to explain everything to the audience
that they can figure it out
and that just that took time and
experience you know going to festivals
and seeing how
audiences responded to my films seeing
how they responded to other films and
just
you know learning to trust both myself
and audiences was the biggest change
for me and not being so on the nose
about my writing
has overriding ever been an issue for
you i know you talked about you had
these
characters with these monologues and
their opinions and things but in terms
of the actual
story has overriding ever been an issue
for you
um i haven't done that much overwriting
uh
blood from stone i definitely chopped a
good chunk of it off i mean i already
knew the film that i had in my mind was
not going to be a 90
film it was going to be i was assuming
at least 145
150 maybe even 155 the fact it's over
two hours
uh my distributors weren't happy about
that but
upon seeing it they're like it works
it's tight it's a tight
two-hour and four-minute movie but um
even with that the script itself did
have some and it was really that it's
still
my natural go-to is i'm going to write
it down and then
so i had a lot of dialogue that was way
too long
you know i'm sure you noticed there's
the scene of the brother and sister in
the bar
talking that goes on for a little while
i love it a few people that love it some
say it's too long
i left it in um i think the actors did
great with it so i
i enjoyed on that level um
but yeah i do find myself doing that and
i often times my first draft and my
second draft
maybe first a third draft there's at
least a 10 page difference of how much
i've cut out
uh frey was the only one that wasn't
that way
frey was just a very short succinct
script
the actual script for that is just over
60 pages
it was a very short succinct one so
and was a lot of the dialogue um improv
no it was just that film has so many
scenes of
i mean there's only so many ways you can
write he looks off in the distance
depressed
and you know but when you're shooting it
and you have
brian's phenomenal performance with
jaron's amazing cinematography
that one line is a minute or two minutes
of the film
and it's an incredibly powerful minute
or two minutes because
of the visuals and the performance in it
but because i wasn't trying to sell the
script i wasn't trying to impress
anybody with the script it was literally
going to be
read by our team i didn't embellish with
a bunch of descriptions or anything like
that i was like
you know the character's name is justin
like justin walks to
uh you know the job interview he you
know then i'd write the job interview
dialogue and then
he walks home i wouldn't you know
embellish and all that because i had in
my head
i knew jaren was going to make it look
great and i knew brian was going to kill
it as a performer so
wrote a really lazy script for that one
probably not the best thing to say to
inspire people to get really good at
being professional writers
um but because like i said i wasn't
trying to sell it i wasn't trying to
impress anybody with it
i just wrote it for me and my little
crew
so that's why that one i got away with
being lazy
i think that's it kind of says a lot in
that that you weren't really writing for
the market
you weren't writing to impress whomever
it was just a story that you really want
to tell you
had a family member that experienced
this you'd met people
and that's where a lot of that came from
it was wild too because uh
when it came out and we got the good
reviews with that i got an email one day
from the academy of motion pictures of
arts and sciences and they requested a
copy of the script for their permanent
library
which was amazing and
i was like i'm kind of embarrassed to
give them this script it's like
you know let me at least create a proper
title page for it
um and uh yeah so it was kind of wild
that like probably my laziest script
so far has been my most successful so
um i don't know what that says about me
as a writer maybe i just
shouldn't try so hard
or that's just the story that you're
writing and how connected you are
i think that's a big part of it is
really like the story and that one just
there was so much of my own
you know i told you about the research i
did getting to know so many
people who were living that life my own
cousin's experiences
it kind of just that one just flowed out
and i had a very specific idea for it so
um i think that's kind of key in writing
is
you know really know what you're writing
have a
have a like really believe it and
just trust it as you're writing it
you